Okay, we will get started.
We're now leaving well, temporarily
leaving the land of systems
to talk about more deep learning stuff
which for you know, we're going to have
two lectures on scaling law and scaling
law adjacent phenomena. So today is
going to be the basics.
We're just going to talk about pretty
basic scaling law stuff, some of the
classic works, how does you know, the
basic idea of scaling laws connect to
maybe things you know about from machine
learning 101. And then in two lectures,
we're going to do the more advanced
version of the scaling laws lecture
where we're going to basically go into
a bunch of modern
open model tech reports, things like new
P and other parameter initializations
and this year I'm going to throw in some
more stuff for optimizers. So there will
be an advanced version of this that that
will try to really get to the cutting
edge. Today we're going to start with
all the really basic stuff.
And due to sort of some scheduling
constraints, next lecture will be
inference. So you're kind of going to go
back and forth. You're going to do
scaling laws then inference and then
scaling laws again.
So scaling laws is really you know, kind
of the following scenario in some ways
or or you run into a very quickly once
you run into the scenario, right? So you
know, you have your very wealthy friend
who has given you 10,000 B200s for a
month and he or she has asked you to
build a very good open source language
model, right? Like they they would like
to get something out of those B200s.
And so you know, you've already put
together your infra team. That's your
assignment to you know,
buddies and you have let's say a good
pre-training data set. That's going to
be the the assignment after this, but
let's say you already have that. And
then you're going to go and train a big
model, right? But there's lots of
choices in training a big model. All the
assignments are the earlier lecture two
stuff that we had earlier where you have
questions like you know, what
architecture should I use? What should
my hyper parameters be? And it's very
scary to run these things on a run that
is basically you know, potentially
millions of dollars
in cost. So how do you really take this
idea of scaling up very seriously? How
do you make sure that your big run is
actually successful?
So of these many choices, some of which
you're going to just copy out of the
literature, right? The stuff that I
talked about earlier in the architecture
lecture is really about kind of well,
you know, adopted best practices and you
will probably just pick some of these
out of a hat. That's fine.
But really let's say you're at the
frontier, you would like to you know,
build something that's actually better
than the best available models today,
you have to start really optimizing
these, right? You can't just copy the
choices of others and get something
that's you know, better than the state
of the art. So how do we do that? Well,
that's going to require us to really
engage with this idea of scaling.
So scaling laws have been one very
powerful tool. You might also call it a
paradigm. I think scaling laws, you
know, if you talk to some people who are
are really in these like big labs doing
scaling work, it's almost kind of like a
way of life. You know, they're like we
really believe in the scaling laws. It's
almost a belief and you'll see why
scaling laws can sometimes be quite
tricky objects.
But really scaling laws are these simple
predictive rules of how to go from small
scale model performance and behavior and
to try to extrapolate them up to large
scale behavior, right? And so the basic
naive way to to approach model training
might be to say I have a big budget. I'm
going to do you know, multiple training
runs on these very big runs and I'm
going to tune hyper parameters on those
big runs, right? But that's very
wasteful.
So instead what I would like to do is I
would like to do all of my optimization
at the small scale and have some simple
rule that allows me to extrapolate small
scale behaviors to large scale
behaviors, right? And if the small scale
large scale are sort of connected by
some very simple sort of robust
connections like regularities of some
kind, then you would have confidence in
this kind of new scaling approach to
optimizing your system. And that's
really what today is all going to be
about. This kind of engineering view of
of a scaling law.
Okay.
And to sort of start with, I'm going to
you know, talk a little bit about
background, right? Because I think
scaling laws are very interesting in
that not only are they kind of the you
know, newest paradigm. Like that's kind
of how a lot of these models are
designed and thought of. But also they
connect very closely to very classical
ideas, right? So if you're a person
that's
a machine learning theorist, right? I
think actually there are some things
that you will really kind of feel at
home with in some ways. So they're kind
of like empirical sample complexities.
And then I'll talk through the history
of of scaling laws of one kind and show
you that this is not something that's
really new. It's something with actually
quite a bit of history and and research
done to it.
Um
So you know, I really really had to put
some math into my slides. I really feel
that the need to do so.
But I think one of the things that I
think is very interesting is that you
know, for the longest time machine
learning has thought about this question
of how will my model perform, right?
Especially from a theory perspective,
right? Like I have this model class, how
good is my model going to be?
And generalization bound is kind of the
theorist answer to this question, right?
So you have you know, your error over
some finite hypothesis class and you say
oh, my error is going to be at most this
much worse than the models performance
on my training set, right? This is you
know, classic generalization bounds.
You can sort of write this down for more
complex classes like smooth densities or
whatever.
But importantly, you know, not only does
this tell you you know, some sort of
performance. Notice that these bounds
are often dependent on the sample size,
right? And so this is kind of telling
you okay, well, this is a theoretical
upper bound on my loss values as a
function of how my training set grows,
right? And in some ways that's very
closely related to this idea of what
happens as I scale up sort of the amount
of data that I have, right? Those are
closely related questions or you might
you know, believe me that that's true.
And if you try to figure out like what
is the very first scaling law paper that
exists, it turns out you can go back
quite far. You can go back to Bell Labs
and Corinna Cortes and you know,
Vladimir Vapnik and these folks that
were doing like very serious you know,
theory work on machine learning, you
know, asked this question. Well,
training classifiers on a really large
data set is often very expensive. We
would like to avoid doing that and to do
so, maybe we can just fit classifiers on
a smaller sample, fit a curve to how
their error rates decay and use that as
a way to estimate their performance,
right? That's almost literally a data
scaling law
back in 1993. Right. So this idea of at
the very least you know, thinking about
how your models performance changes as a
function of data set size is just a very
classical one and there's kind of a lot
of work that supports this kind of idea.
I just want to connect this to some of
these older ideas so you don't really
think of scaling laws as this like very
new purely neural thing. I think it's a
idea that has a lot of roots in
empirical machine learning and also
connections to theoretical machine
learning.
And if you start to sort of look at the
history of this, you know, there's a lot
of people that have said, you know,
isn't it the case that maybe instead of
spending money on algorithm development,
maybe we should just go collect more
data because if we plot how the
performance of our systems, you know,
behave as a function of the amount of
data that we have, it turns out that you
know, they are all increasing or
improving in predictable ways. Like
Branco and Bril I think is one of the
canonical sort of NLP references I think
in sort of how the amount of data and
and thinking about scaling is a really
valid way of improving system
performance, right? So there's lots of
you know, ways of thinking about this.
And I think
there's also work by other NLP folks
like Collobert et al in 2012. This is
one of our earlier works on like
different kinds of functional forms for
scaling laws where once again they're
increasing the amount of data that
they're using to train. I think in this
case machine translation systems so they
have blue scores.
And they're you know, asking like what
is the right functional form for how a
models performance behaves as a function
of increased data amount and they you
know, maybe surprisingly or not
surprisingly end up with the same power
laws which is power three and four as
really we do today, right? For the rest
of the lecture, you're going to keep
seeing essentially these polynomial
functions power three and power four
as I talk about scaling laws. And you
know, we kind of knew about a lot of
this
back in the 2010s that like these kinds
of functional forms were very predictive
of model behavior as we scaled them up.
And then finally, you know, I really
like mentioning this paper because for
whatever reason, they don't get or
Hassabis et al don't get cited quite as
much as they should. I think the origins
of neural scaling I would kind of point
back to Hassabis in 2017.
Really kind of a very forward-looking
work in many ways
that built these scaling laws as a
function of data set size for wide
variety of systems like different kinds
of speech recognition systems, machine
translation systems, language models
and they showed that you know, these
things follow these like nice polynomial
trends across a really large number of
domains.
And you know, it was really ahead of its
time because 2017 was long before some
of the earlier sort of OpenAI scaling
laws and so on in in the 2020s.
And you know, they talked about stuff
that we talk about today like emergence.
Like where suddenly you know,
models might show certain kinds of
capabilities because accuracy is a much
more discontinuous measure than losses.
And really you know, scaling by compute
that if we have systems that scale
predictably to large training data, then
really compute is going to be really
important. And then finally, you know,
since we're scaling by compute, well,
speed and systems optimization is going
to turn into accuracy. So in some ways
like a lot of the things that we see
today like the phenomena of like system
scaling and so on, we could have really
known or you know, I could have known in
2017 had I sort of read and thought
about a lot of these scaling laws papers
back then and thought about them more
seriously. So um
kind of like the to
mention that paper in in every one of
these scaling law lectures I give just
to say, you know, a lot of these
phenomena were known far before the
modern era or like the modern language
modeling era and that, you know, it's
it's possible to have known the the
regime that we're in even before seeing
these large language models. I think
that's very cool to to know. Um
okay. Um any questions about this sort
of like semi-historical part? Yeah.
It was and I'm wondering if those are
just found empirically or is there some
kind of like way we can justify all of
this?
Um you're asking about these scaling
laws and where they come from. Um these
are sort of pure curve fitting
exercises. Um
I think uh I will talk a little bit
about where scaling laws can come from
um and why polynomials are arguably a
very natural class of scaling laws. Um
but I think um
there's no golden rule that these are
the only ones. I will say though that um
you know, in some place theory provides
a very rich place where these scaling
law functional forms can come from
because theory is often thinking a lot
about, you know, how do error rates
decay as a function of various objects
and they give you candidate functional
forms of various kinds. Um physicists
are also very good at this because they
like thinking about limits like how do
the limits behave and that gives you
different um
uh scaling law functional forms.
Cool.
Okay.
All right. Any other questions?
Good.
So now I'm going to start talking about
um more modern neural language model
scaling um and I'm going to start with
data scaling laws because I think to me
they're the most simple and natural
objects.
Um
talking about data scaling laws also
allows me to sort of walk you through
very step-by-step on kind of how we
might sort of um
uh guess what the functional form of a
scaling law might be and why the
polynomial form is a natural one. And
then I'm going to start talking about,
you know, hyper parameters and
architectures and all sorts of other
more exotic objects um that are going to
be harder to justify from intuition but
still turn out to have very nice uh
scaling law behaviors.
Um
I think one of the things that's
remarkable about kind of this scaling
law style analysis has been that these
power law relationships seem to hold for
a huge variety of different factors. Um
so the basic ones that we see in
pre-training and those are going to be
the ones that I'm going to talk about
today um you know, the the usual ones
that you see are, you know, compute on
the x-axis. This is log compute, sorry,
on the x-axis. Log of test loss on the
y-axis or log of the data set on x-axis,
log of loss on y-axis, log of parameters
on x-axis, log of loss once again on
y-axis, right? So we can get a variety
of different x-axes that you might think
of as resources in the log axis all of
them sort of linearize log test loss
here.
Um
you can see also much more exotic um
uh scaling laws. You can see scaling
laws that, you know, are are um
basically the the equivalent to these in
downstream benchmarks. In those cases
you expect to see a sigmoid
um functional form as a function of
compute or compute-like quantities.
Um there's even been, you know, many
works recently um more on the
forecasting side where people are doing
things like putting dates as the x-axis
and strangely enough, at least for these
plots like the upper envelope of these
curves are often linear in various forms
of um capabilities. Um there's no reason
that, you know, on this this bottom side
the more exotic scaling laws need to be
true um
but it is it turns out to be the case
that I guess language model performance
is often much more regular as a function
of scale and resources than it initially
might appear.
Um
so to begin with I'm going to start with
data scaling laws and data scaling laws
are a very simple kind of univariate
relationship that we're going to think
about, right? So in this world we're
going to fix our model training
procedure um and in general um unless I
say otherwise the models are going to
generally be bigger than the data set
size
and I'm going to increase my data set
size, you know, in a regular way and I'm
going to see how the error reduces,
right? And what we expect out of this
relationship in general it's going to be
monotone-ish if we tune our hyper
parameters well, right? Because we have
more data more data should help us, you
know, do better at our task the error
should decrease. And if you're doing
something like classification or even
for for next token prediction you should
really go from like random guessing to
some sort of like entropy-like object
where you can't do any better than sort
of the the irreducible error of your
task, right? That's the noise floor. So
we're going to have some sigmoidal-like
object over here. So this is generally
what we expect out of our system.
So um we're going to start with an
empirical observation and, you know, you
can and and should, you know, make this
on your own. You'll you'll make
something that looks roughly like this
in parts of assignment three um which
is, you know, if we just have a very big
model much bigger than our data set and
we increase the data set size and we put
that on the log axis and on the y-axis,
you know, we have log test loss once
again um you will find that the two um
sort of uh the points that you plot will
form a very clear linear trend, right?
Um I've taken this from Kaplan in 2020.
This is um I'm going to refer repeatedly
to this paper. This one's um OpenAI's
neural scaling laws paper. Um they have
a lot of lovely uh ablations and a lot
of lovely data.
Now um
this relationship where I've plotted a
line on a log-log plot this is a
scale-free or power law relationship.
Um and what does that mean, right? If I
have a line on a log-log plot um many of
you to many of you this is probably
obvious but just to really emphasize
this, right? If something's linear in a
log-log plot what does that mean? Well,
it means that the error that I have is
decaying polynomially, right? And and
also it usually means that I'm very far
away from my asymptote, right? Cuz once
I approach my asymptote I'm going to,
you know, taper off rather than have a
line.
Um so let's go through an example just
to show you how uh scaling law arises
very naturally on a very simple
estimation problem.
Okay.
So forget language modeling for the
moment. Um this was a language modeling
class but now it is a statistics class
for the next one slide or actually two
slides. No. What maybe three slides. Um
so in this case, right? What I want to
do is I want to estimate the mean uh
from a bunch of data. Um and so I have
an input it's drawn from a Gaussian and
I'm going to estimate the mean of this
object, right? I just write down the
empirical mean and then you can write
down what the the error is. So what's
the expected error? Well, each of these
guys is Gaussian and I know that the mu
hat is Gaussian so I can write down the
error that's going to be sigma squared
over n, right? Okay. So well, if you
look at this this is kind of a scaling
law, right? I've written down the error,
right? And the error, if I log that, is
a function of log n, right? Log n being
the log x-axis, right? Um so in general,
you know, if you can come up with
anything that is essentially uh 1 over n
to the alpha plus some constant, you
know, when you plot that on a log-log
plot subtracting out the constant term
you're going to get a scaling law,
right? So so anything of this form where
you have polynomial decay in errors is
going to end up giving you a a scaling
law. And of course, in parametric
estimation like mean estimation or
regression, um you of course expect a
polynomial rate, right? You don't really
expect anything else.
Um
and, you know, if you've taken your your
stats estimation courses you know that
essentially all the classical models you
are expected to have a 1 over n scaling,
right? If you fit a regression or so on
you might get d over n or or whatever
else.
Um and so if this is true and this is
the origins of scaling laws, if we plot
our our lines we should expect to see um
roughly a slope of minus one, right? Cuz
that's the exponent on the x, right? Y
equals minus x plus c.
Um if we fit our neural scaling laws we
will find that our exponents are quite
different. Um these exponents uh
I've I've taken these from these two on
the left from Hessness. I've taken the
one on the right from Kaplan. They're
about negative point one, negative point
three, negative point one, roughly
speaking, right? Um and so what does
that mean? That means this is much
slower than estimating a mean or
estimating like a linear regression,
right? So this much much slower
convergence rate. Still polynomial but
much slower.
Now, this is kind of interesting. It's
saying that we're getting, you know,
these kind of nice polynomial rates but
the exponents are not so great, right?
They're negative point one.
Where might you get an estimation rate
like this? Well, you would get this if
your model was kind of more
non-parametric, right? I promise this
will be the last statistics slide of
this lecture. Um let's say that I want
to estimate now instead of a mean an
arbitrary smooth function, right? So one
thing I could do is if I'm doing a
regression problem, right? I have my
inputs x1 through xn um let's say
they're in the unit box. I have a little
bit of Gaussian noise and I have an
unknown function f that I would like to
estimate. Um a trivial estimator for
this is I can take my, you know, space I
can cut it up into little 2D boxes of
length n to the negative one to the
fourth. Um
and then what's our estimation error?
I'll have square root n boxes. Each box
is going to get square root n samples.
Um and the error is going to be roughly
one over square root of n or something,
right?
Um and in general if I have a
D-dimensional function I would like to
estimate, you know, in this kind of very
non-parametric arbitrary way my error is
going to be roughly equal to n to the
negative one over D, right? So my
scaling is going to be y equals negative
one over D times x. And so now these
kinds of more flexible functions,
functions that are more flexible than
the linear class, now have rates in
their scaling laws that are not just
one, they're one over D. And so one, you
know, mental sort of model that you
could have is that the neural networks I
was showing you in these slides are
behaving kind of like non-parametric
regressors in 10 dimensions, right? Like
a nearest neighbor or other kinds of uh
estimators in 10 dimensions. That's
roughly the rate at which they learn
from data. That's kind of a cool thing
to be able to know just by looking at
some of these scaling laws.
Um some people have argued this more
strongly. Um
Barri et al. and some other uh scaling
law theory folks have argued that like,
you know, the scaling law exponents are
actually like literally telling us that
the neural network is behaving like a
non-parametric smoother and so on and so
forth. It's an interesting set of
arguments and you can sort of buy that
intuition to whatever extent you'd like.
I don't quite know how much I truly
truly buy this argument. There's some,
you know, of the evidence might be a
little sketchy. It relies on estimators
of intrinsic dimension.
But it's sort of an interesting thing to
think about that somehow these exponents
are telling us, you know, how fast are
these neural networks really learning?
Okay.
So,
actually I'll pause for the moment here.
That's really the the end of the really
basic data scaling law of like one, you
know, distribution and you sample from
it and you learn from it. Is that all
kind of clear? Like the examples and so
on.
Good. Oh, yes, question.
You said
model is always larger than data set
size. Do you mean like one-to-one like
number of parameters, number of tokens
or what do you
Yeah, that's a that's a good question.
So, the question was something like,
what what do I mean when I say the model
is larger than the data set size? What I
mean is,
when the model gets small relative to
the data, like you have way more data
than you have model size, you enter this
irreducible error regime, right? Like
you basically fitted the data as well as
you can for your model class and you
can't do any better no matter how much
data you add, right?
So, we want to, you know, when we're
thinking about scaling laws, we usually
want to think about this power law
regime. Which is the sort of simpler
case. Either that or you explicitly fit
the asymptote and then you correct for
it. Those are kind of the two things.
So, when I say the model is larger than
the data, it can be basically any amount
that it's larger than the the data as
long as it's in this power law regime.
Usually like, you know, 10 times bigger
than the data will have you.
Cool. Good. Okay. Now we are back to
other data scaling laws, right? So,
data scaling laws by themselves are not
quite as useful as you'd like them to
be. They just tell you how fast does my
model learn, right? And that's kind of
useful for forecasting. It's not useful
for very much else. If you want to do
engineering, you are probably interested
in other questions like, you know, what
is my optimal data mixture? Like what is
the best way for me to pick my training
data for my model? Very useful
engineering question. Should I repeat my
data or should I, you know, just, you
know, not repeat my data? Save the
compute for something else.
Or, you know, maybe I should repeat some
high quality stuff and, you know, not
repeat the low quality stuff. Like I
could I could do various other things
with our prediction. Right? There's a
lot of different engineering decisions I
can make with data. So, how can scaling
laws help us make some of those
decisions?
Um,
and I think one of the things that's
interesting is if we, you know, think a
little bit about how classical models
behave, right? Data scaling laws, if we
think about their origins as essentially
empirical versions of generalization
bounds, they kind of tell us, well, you
know, data set composition for many
models really affect the offset of these
scaling laws, but their slopes are
actually determined by kind of the model
class. They're not really determined by
the distribution themselves. So, the
slopes might remain the same and only
the intercepts might change. And the
intercept might actually be really
interestingly shaped. So, this is a case
of a toy model with a linear regression
with two different things you can sample
from. If you get only one kind of data,
you know, it's the errors are high no
matter what. You actually want a mixture
of both, right? So, if you write down
kind of how this intercept behaves, you
actually start to get some very
interesting insights about how having
more data diversity is very helpful. But
what does this kind of practically mean?
Well, practically speaking, what this
means is you can actually fit data
scaling laws on mixtures and that can
help you do some data,
sorry, pre-training data optimization.
So, what does this mean? Let's say you
have
two data sources for simplicity. You
have news and you have Wikipedia and you
want to know how much news to use and
how much Wikipedia to use. How can you
determine that? Well, you can train
really small models on really small
amount of data and then you can
basically train or you can fit a
function of, you know, how different
mixture levels affect your performance.
You can do this while you scale up your
models little by little and you can see
how the trends change and you can try to
extrapolate that out the exact same way
as you would extrapolate out a data
scaling law and then you can ask which
one will be optimal if I keep scaling it
out to my full training law. Right? So,
this is this is a very simple idea
of essentially fitting a functional form
at small amount of compute, finding the
minimum and then scaling that guy out.
So, this is a
data mixing laws paper.
Unfortunately, I think if you talk to
anyone who's done a lot of these data
mixture work will tell you,
reality is a lot more noisy than kind of
this ideal world would suggest.
And really what has, as far as I know,
happened in many cases is you end up
training a bunch of small models, you
pick the best data mix from the small
model and you just scale that guy up. No
scaling law required. And data decide,
if you're interested in this kind of
thing, is is a nice large scale
sort of empirical study of these kinds
of data mixture things. And what they
found was actually, if you don't fit a
scaling law and instead you just pick
the best data mix at the small scale,
that works well.
For what it's worth, that's consistent
with the argument that the intercepts
differ but the slopes don't change
because if the slopes don't change, the
best mixture at small scale is also the
best mixture at large scale.
Okay.
Um,
another really interesting set of
questions
that I'll also mention in the context of
data is repetition.
I think it's increasingly the case that
compute is growing. The amount of data
that we have is not growing. And so
there's a lot of people interested in
questions of what happens when you
repeat data more and more times.
And there was a nice study a few years
back called scaling data constrained
language models where they roughly show
something like up to four epochs with
standard training recipes, you you just
don't get hurt at all.
But if you go past that point, then
actually your your realized scaling law,
this sort of dark curve, it's much worse
than sort of the projected scaling law
if you had fresh data. That's the dash
line over here. And you can also once
again write down a modified functional
form that's generally predictive of the
behavior of this scaling law under
repetition.
Um,
and we can take this idea even more to
the extreme. This was kind of recent
work with Perseus, one of our co-advised
students, where we were asking like,
okay, like what happens if you take this
idea to the extreme and you just, you
know, consider infinite amounts of
compute. So, you're allowed to epoch as
many times as you want, like an infinite
amount of times. What is the best thing
that you can get out of this system?
Well, turns out you can't just keep
repeating passes over the data. You
can't keep making your models bigger.
Those have diminishing returns. And so
you end up reaching for other things
like, you know, ensembling your models
to try to squeeze more and more out of
your data. But really, I think the one
thing that I'll point out that's really
interesting is, you know, your standard
data scaling law is here in the red.
It's a very nice, predictable, you know,
improvement in performance as you
increase the amount of data. You know,
we do all sorts of interventions like
regularizing and adding ensembles, you
get improvements in performance but the
slopes look actually surprisingly
similar. This is a a lesson that you'll
learn
once you start fitting your own scaling
laws that very very often
your slopes don't change. Often the
interventions that you do just change
the intercept of the scaling laws.
Um, one last thing that I'll mention cuz
I like this paper in the context of
scaling laws
and scaling in general is that a lot of
the phenomena we care about in data is
actually very scale dependent. And one
example of this is data filtering,
right? So, if you or I, you know,
tomorrow decide to filter some data for
the models we're training, we would
probably filter very aggressively,
right? We would only keep the highest
quality stuff because both you and I
don't have very much compute, right? So,
we can't train on all the internet
anyway. We might as well filter down to
sort of the most high quality stuff.
On the other hand, if you have a lot of
compute, right? Then you want to train
on more and more stuff because you're
going to not want to repeat on this very
high quality data. So, as you get more
and more compute, your filters kind of
become looser and looser and potentially
you start training on stuff that's lower
and lower quality, right? So, a lot of
the things that we often think about
statically, like things like data
filtering or the quality of data, are
actually much more dynamic. As you as
you increase scale, you have to think
about where am I going to get the rest
of the data, right? Like the filters
can't stay fixed as a function of the
data. And certainly like the optimal
filters turn out to not be fixed as a
function of scale.
Okay.
So, that's it for data scaling laws.
This is the part that I think is most
straightforward to understand. Even as
kind of like a, you know, stats
ML-minded person, like this stuff is all
very simple and straightforward to me.
You increase data, performance gets
better in a very predictable way, right?
I think this is uncontroversial. The
fact that it does so polynomially for
such a big model is still kind of cool,
but nothing really crazy. So, hopefully
this is, you know, reasonable to all of
you that there's so much predictability
when you increase the amount of data.
Oh, yes.
So, on the slide for the pre-training
under infinite compute, so, that
like graph on the right is like linear
in both the loss and
data set size.
Whereas like the previous example I gave
was like log-log scale. I was wondering
why it's linear though.
Yeah, so so this is this is a I mean,
bad axis. Herman and I just talked about
bad axes like this.
You know, this is actually doubling,
right? So, it looks linear but it's
actually log scale.
You fixed it now? You fixed it now?
Okay.
And the Y axis here, it doesn't look
logged but the range of this is so small
that linear logs are basically the same.
If you look at the fitted functional
forms here, right? These are still
polynomials. So, we're fitting the same
functional forms and those are the ones
that are plotted here. Um this is
another point. I'll get to it at the end
of the lecture. Um
if you only have a tiny slice of a
compute range, it's very, very difficult
to tell if something is scaling
polynomially or if something's scaling
exponentially, right? Because Taylor
approximations are a thing. Everything
looks linear if you kind of zoom in
enough, right? Um and so, whether this
is polynomial or some other functional
form, you want to be always a little bit
careful and skeptical.
Okay. Okay.
All right.
So, that was scaling laws for data. Um
in many ways straightforward. Now, I
want to sort of talk about more exotic
forms of scaling and sort of scaling
laws for for model engineering of
various kinds. Um so, what we're going
to do now is we're going to try to
design large language models. Um you
know, maybe you're a radical and you
believe that maybe LSTMs are the future.
Like, why can't I use a LSTM instead of
a transformer? You know, I want to blow
my B200 run on my LSTMs. Or, you know,
maybe you're a different kind of radical
and you want to train on SGD. Like, why
can't I train on SGD? Um you might also
wonder, like, if you have a limited
amount of resources, you have different
ways to to spend it, right? Like, maybe
you should train models longer, maybe
you should train bigger models, maybe I
should go collect more data. There's all
sorts of tradeoffs always at play, and
scaling laws give us quantitative ways
of making these tradeoffs, hopefully.
I'm going to start off with some simple
hyperparameter questions. Um
things like, how do I choose my
architecture or optimizer? Um things
that I talked about in um the second
lecture. And there, I gave you the
perspective of maybe you can study what
other people do. Now, I'm going to try
to give you a first principle answers to
those questions um with a little bit of
a different set of tradeoffs, right? So,
you have to believe in scaling laws in
this lecture, but as long as you do, you
get to sort of try things on your own
and find out.
Okay.
The very first question we might start
with is to say, are transformers really
better than LSTMs? Um
you know, LSTMs, they can work okay,
too. Like, they will fit distributions.
You know, with the advent of things like
Mamba, we know that SSMs can work. So,
are they better? The brute force way to
answer this question is to train a big
LSTM, GPT-3, or even bigger class of
models. Um the scaling law way would be
to train a bunch of smaller models,
um and say, I'm going to train my
transformer across a different variety
of compute ranges, and I'm going to
train different LSTMs with different
numbers of layers on, you know, once
again, a variety of different compute
ranges.
Now, what does this show? This shows,
you know, LSTMs have, you know,
definitely different intercept, maybe
even different slope than the
transformer. And because of this,
probably don't want to pick a LSTM,
right? Um this plot would justify
scaling up the transformer um instead of
the LSTM.
And if you look at a lot of the
architecture papers today, like, you go
look at the Mamba paper or um the gated
DeltaNet papers, they will always have a
plot that looks like this, right? Where
you have, you know, vanilla transformer,
our really cool model, and our really
cool model is usually either on top or
below, because that's what would prove
that your model is doing better, right?
And you certainly don't want something
where your slopes are worse, because
that means as you scale up larger and
larger, your models will eventually do
worse, right? So, this is one way of
really reasoning about architectures
without uh training gigantic models.
Um there haven't been, I think, quite as
many
uh recent and good uh architecture
scaling law papers. Um I think the one
that is relatively recent and that I
like quite a lot is is by E T and others
at Google um back when they were
publishing this kind of work, where they
did a whole bunch of scaling studies on
on T5-style models, where they sort of
trained larger and larger variants of T5
models on many different architectures.
Um and I think one thing that's really
cool and one of the reasons why I still
bring this paper up is, you know, they
kind of capture exactly the architecture
changes that we implement today in our
frontier models, right? So, things like,
you know, performer, which is a uh um
efficient attention, that doesn't scale
very well. Like, we do not implement
those.
Um
you know, the things that we implement
are the gated linear unit, right? Red
line better than green line throughout
the scaling trends. Um switch
transformer, I don't know what happened
with their biggest run, but, you know,
generally speaking, it's got good
scaling trends.
Um
and
uh I forgot Oh, mixture of soft max.
Actually, we don't do this anymore, but
this is probably an effective
intervention given the scaling trends.
Um so, you kind of see that through the
scaling trends, um even though a lot of
these, you know, papers were operating
at much, much smaller compute scales
than what we operate today,
um they're able to see the kinds of
architecture trends that are driving uh
frontier model development back then,
right? And I think this is why a lot of
people kind of use scaling laws as like
a really almost paradigmatic way of
saying, like, "Oh, if it doesn't show up
in the scaling law, it's not a good
intervention." Because in some ways,
um a lot of the past work has captured
what we see today.
Good.
Okay.
Um going beyond architectures, we can
extend this kind of analysis to all
sorts of other things that we might um
want to understand. We might ask, okay,
is SGD better or worse than Adam? Um if
you do the scaling law analysis, this
one's by Hessness, you'll see very clear
trends. Um this is once again the really
mysterious thing of, you know, the
intercepts are different, but the slopes
are very similar, right? Um if you fix
the data and you fix the models, like,
slopes are often very, very similar. I
I'm very surprised by this every time I
see it, and yet it's very true. Um it's
rare to get uh different slopes, even
with an intervention as big as SGD to
Adam, right? Like, if you were the one
training with SGD or Adam, you would you
would think that's a huge change.
Scaling trends remain roughly the same.
Um in this case, this is a uh language
modeling with a recurrent highway net.
Um similarly, in uh lecture two, I told
you about aspect ratios. Like, how do
you pick your depth-to-width tradeoff?
And I told you, well, you know, you can
just pick some random number that's, you
know, some roughly reasonable. It's like
four times the reasonable multiplier.
But, if you were doing this kind of
scaling analysis, you could kind of know
much more precisely what is happening.
So, um the first thing you could do is
you could look at scaling trends as a
function of layers. And you would
immediately see that having extremely
few layers is very, very bad for your
model. Like, if you have one layer, you
know, you're you're not going anywhere.
That's a terrible, terrible scaling
trend. Greater than one layer, actually,
it's surprisingly more competitive.
Although, you do see that at every
compute level, more layers, at least in
in this case, is is better, right? And
if you you can do a much more
fine-grained study, which they do do in
Kaplan,
where, you know, you try to identify
what you might call scale-invariant
quantities, like, the aspect ratio,
right? The number of layers is not a
scale-invariant quantity. As you make
your model bigger, you do want more
layers, right? But, as you make your
model bigger, maybe the aspect ratio,
the optimal one, should stay the same,
right? This one is scale-invariant. And
so, if we look at the aspect ratio, we
see that at different model sizes, you
know, we get basically the same minima
around 100 uh D model for every layer,
um or maybe a little bit less. And it
does shift a little bit, right? Like,
there is a shift towards um sort of uh
aspect ratio that is smaller for deeper
models, but for the most part, the
minima stays roughly similar.
You can do similar kinds of analysis um
for things like attention head dimension
and others. And if you look at the
Kaplan paper, um they do quite a good
job at doing all of this. And this is
one way that you can be confident about
your scaling strategy, right? So, if
your scaling strategy is, I'm going to
fix my aspect ratio and I'm going to
scale up, you can make plots like this
and convince yourself, you know, we're
probably good because our our optimum
isn't shifting too much as I go to
larger and larger and larger models.
One thing that's important, and this is
a you know, this is a huge can of worms,
and a in a sufficiently big can of worms
that I will talk about it on more than
one slide. It will come back.
Um
you know, not all parameters are created
equal. And because not all parameters
are created equal, your scaling laws may
look good or bad depending on how you
define what a parameter is.
Um so, in the Kaplan paper, they made
this observation that if they drew their
scaling laws for for depth um with the
embedding parameters, they got these
like very funky-looking scaling laws.
And they said, "Oh, this is no good at
all, no good at all," right? Because
it's no good at all, they decided that
they were going to exclude all the all
the embedding parameters, and they were
only going to count the non-embedding
parameters, because
you know, you could justify it to
yourself saying, "These are the
parameters that are doing computation or
whatever." Um
you know, we're going to see later that
this is going to have non-trivial
implications on the validity of some of
the results. But, the point here is,
scaling laws aren't kind of magic. I
think, you know, Percy likes to make
this point that, like, scaling laws and
all these kinds of, you know,
predictability across scales is
engineered, right? Like, they don't
happen automatically. We need to sort of
pick the right kinds of, you know,
x-axes to look at. We need to make sure
that the hyperparameters for these
things are set right. And only under
those conditions does it become possible
to get predictable scaling across many
orders of magnitude compute, right? So,
um this is kind of what a lot of scaling
law researchers do, right? They think
about what the right way is to get very
predictable scaling.
Now, related to this, I think are are
very interesting recent papers on um
things like scaling for mixture of
experts. You know, now that mixture of
experts is kind of, you would say, the
dominant way of training large models,
you know, it is quite important to think
about what is the value or what is a
parameter in this new world where number
of parameters and the number active
parameters are kind of decoupled. Um and
there's a nice uh clean analysis by some
folks at Apple and MIT um that show the
sort of scaling trends as a function of
um
function of both parameters and active
parameters. And kind of the cool thing
that you see is as you start to train um
bigger and bigger models like if you you
know increase the amount of total
parameters on the x-axis over here and
you want to minimize your loss you're
going to end up with sort of more sparse
and sparse models. See how the color
becomes darker and darker and darker
right? Similarly here if you like
the number of active parameters kind of
decreases as a function of MOE sparsity
and you sort of get the result that I
think is somewhat intuitive here which
is you know you can draw these sort of
surfaces for every sort of compute
amount you can ask okay I would would I
rather spend that compute on active
parameters
or you know in how much sparsity do I
want right? I can vary my sparsity
without really changing the amount of
compute that I'm spending.
Now given that you can ask okay what
happens if I add more sort of empty
parameters same active parameters but
sort of more total parameters. As you
move from sort of back on the plot to in
front of the front of the plot you see
kind of the losses are improving right?
So in other words
this is saying that the parameters in
MOE that are not active are still
helping you reduce your loss which is
kind of cool and you can kind of write
down what the functional forms of this
are. I won't go into to that part in
more detail but you know the point here
is to say all of these kinds of
quantities that we care about in
optimizing a MOE are things that have
sort of predictable scaling and
regularities.
Okay.
And the two things I want to now talk
about
are actually really yeah two things that
I now want to talk about. When you're
going to train a new big model actually
most of the things that I talk about are
fixed right? You're you're probably all
not radical enough that you're going to
switch to a LSTM you're probably going
to pick like I don't know a deep seek
for inspired MOE or something right? And
you're probably going to pick
architecture choices that are tried and
tested. You're not going to really throw
everything out. But two things that you
really do have to maybe sort of reinvent
in some sense is the batch size and the
learning rate right? If you train your
deep learning models you know that you
have to you know be very about the
combination of your batch size and
learning rate right? You change one you
have to change the other.
Now batch size we know from the previous
lecture is very tricky for another
reason. We want the batch size to be as
big as possible because a big batch size
gives us opportunity for parallelization
right? Remember data parallel requires
large batch size.
So now having said all that what we
really want to know is how large can we
make our batch size before we start to
suffer right? That's the relevant
systems question. And you also want to
know how does that change as a function
of model size? Okay.
So given that preface there is this you
know very important idea
that is used in a variety of papers and
talked about very frequently called the
critical batch size.
The critical batch size is roughly this
idea that up until a certain point when
you start to get diminishing returns
there is returns perfect returns to
increase batch size right? So I might
call this the noise limited regime. So
in the noise limited regime every
additional element that you throw in
your batch reduces the gradient noise in
your SGD step right? And the since your
variance limited that reduction in
variance is very very helpful right?
That that gives you big returns. So this
is the regime in which you have perfect
scaling. You're doing about as well as
you can given the amount of extra
examples that you're processing.
As you sort of get to a certain point
where you've reached kind of the noise
scale of your gradients you get to a
point where you are no longer variance
limited. You're now bias limited. What
does that mean? Well remember in
gradient descent you're looking at kind
of the local structure of your objective
you you don't have global sort of view
of where sort of the minimum is right?
So no matter how low noise I am I'm only
going to point in this light blue
direction over here right? And there's
always a disagreement between my local
descent direction and kind of where the
global optimum is.
Because of that at a certain point I'm
going to get diminishing returns because
now my limiting factor is no longer
variance it is kind of this bias term
right? So now I'm bias limited past this
point over here.
And so critical batch is kind of a rule
of thumb you might call it or a
convenient trade-off point where you
sort of say this is the point at which
we're starting to cross over from our
perfect scaling regime to our
ineffective scaling regime. And so it
gives you a good rule of thumb of where
to be setting your batch size. If you
want your batch size to be as big as
possible without suffering these like
huge efficiency losses. Okay hopefully
that idea is very clear.
Now critical batch size is kind of a
strange object it is derived from a
variety of of sort of complicated
calculations about you know the local
quadratic approximations to the
objective. But I will maybe give you the
mechanical steps of what is actually
used to estimate this quantity.
Um
So what you do is first you pick a
target loss. You know target loss might
be some number that you want to hit. So
your goal is to hit this target loss as
quickly as possible right? That's my
goal right now.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
sweep over all the different batch sizes
or number of different batch sizes and
I'm going to write down the number of
steps that I needed to reach my target
loss and the number of examples that
were needed to get to that target loss.
Of course number one and two are related
by a batch size factor right? The number
of steps times my batch size is equal to
the number of examples.
Now through some calculations
open AI folks and others
argue that this is the rough functional
form that we should follow that the
number of steps that you need and the
number of examples that you need are
inversely related with you know this
Smin which is the minimum number of
possible steps and the minimum number of
examples sort of normalizing these two
quantities. And so there's kind of a
trade-off between these two right? If
you want to minimize the number of
examples you're going to have a lot of
steps and if you want to minimize the
number of steps you're going to need a
lot of examples right? That's a very
natural trade-off right? And if you
increase or decrease your batch size
you're going to have trade-offs that go
one side or the other.
Now they argue the goal now should be to
balance these two sides. I want to make
sure that my number of steps term and
the number of examples terms are roughly
balanced with each other and if you
solve for that you're going to get this
this particular solution which is that
the critical batch size is the minimum
number of examples that I need divided
by the minimum number of steps that I
need right? And these two are kind of
estimated by fitting this to sort of the
the observed data that I have.
This is going to balance both sides of
the equation. It's going to give me a
little bit more number of steps than
optimal. It's going to require a little
bit more examples than optimal but it
balances the two sides and you can kind
of think of this
as improve
optimizing the convergence rate without
blowing up the number of steps that you
you need.
There's another added point that I won't
really belabor because this gets even
more into the weeds. You should really
read the critical batch size paper if
you're interested into this where one of
their arguments is estimating this is
quite complicated. You can do this by
just looking at the ratio of the
gradient covariance and the squared norm
of your gradient. Um
Okay. So why is that even in the scaling
lecture right? Like this is this is a
thing that is is not really related to
scaling so far. The reason why this is
in the scaling lecture is because the
first of all the critical batch size is
a reasonable batch size to pick. That's
a batch size that balances sort of
convergence rate and the size of the
batch right? So if I want to pick my
batch size equal to my critical batch
size you might ask how does this thing
scale as a function of my target loss
right? Target loss can be thought of as
compute right? If I want to have a model
that is better and better and better
right? What is the batch size that I I
should use right? And the reason why
this is in the scaling law lecture is as
you go down in scale in the loss right?
So your loss is improving the amount of
critical batch size increases and it
increases in this very predictable way
which is once again a power law right?
So this is the the relationship that
they argue
which is roughly like inverse polynomial
in batch size.
So given this this is actually quite
nice because what this is saying is if
you have a really large scale training
run where you go all the way to the
right of this plot your batch sizes can
be quite large right? And that kind of
makes sense. As you get the closer and
closer and closer to the minimum the
value of variance reduction increases
right? Because you're you're trying to
optimize finer and finer and finer
grained objects the noise matters a lot
more once you're minimizing really
really tiny differences.
Okay.
So that's the batch size story.
The other side right? So the two
quantities remember that you're going to
always have to tune is batch size and
learning rate. The learning rate side of
the story is also a little bit
complicated. I'll go into this much more
detail
in the advanced scaling lecture.
But learning rates generally shift.
I think this is a good mental picture
for how to think about learning rates in
the standard world that that you start
with which is let's say that you have
just like a MLP right? Like just a
standard neural network of some kind.
I'm not going to do depth scaling. I'm
only going to do width scaling. Now if
I'm doing width scaling the bigger my
model right? The bigger my model the
smaller my learning rate should be and
the reason why my learning rate should
be smaller is because I have you know
bigger more parameters and changing more
things at once maybe I should move less
right? Kind of makes sense.
And so you and in fact there's a kind of
rule of thumb that maybe you want to
scale by one over the width. That's a
very commonly known rule of thumb that
you know you want to just decrease the
learning rate regularly as a function of
your width and that will give you a rule
of thumb to scale your learning rate.
There is kind of another
school of thought or another set of
tricks that people do, which is that
people also rescale the network in
various ways. They will change the
initialization sizes, and they will
change kind of the step sizes of the
optimizer or for various parts of the
network in order to to force the model
to have the same
uh learning rate minimum across scales.
Um and this is a idea um that is called
μP and others like it. Um
some people have reported great success
with these kinds of approaches. Um
others have reported less success. The
two ways basically of setting a learning
rate um for large-scale runs really is
kind of captured in this thought. In one
way, you can try to estimate what these
minima are and try to predict what your
minimum will be. And the way in which
the minimum changes is pretty
predictable, so this is not a crazy
idea. Or you can reparameterize your
model to try to keep the learning rate
minimum the same, and then just pick
your best learning rate and go, right?
Those are the two philosophies to
picking your learning rate. Both of them
have been uh applied successfully at
scale. There are large-scale training
runs that have used both approaches. Um
I think anecdotally
um it does seem like more people are
maybe favoring the scaling law approach,
um but both are certainly viable
approaches. Um I'll talk in detail about
uh both of these next next next lecture.
Okay.
Um so, before I get into to kind of the
last part um of this lecture where I
want to talk about not quite pitfalls,
but various you know details of of
scaling law things.
Um one thing I want to end this section
with is the idea that upstream and
downstream performance can be quite
different.
So, if you look at something like, you
know, uh log likelihood. This is from
the ETE, you know, architectures paper.
Um
you know, you you find that perplexity
and uh negative perplexity in this case,
uh parameters are very correlated. Like
the more parameters you have, the better
your model very predictably, right? This
is this is a very beautiful linear
trend. Now, you're like, "Okay, this is
great. Now, we're going to ship our best
model NL-12." Um turns out NL-12 is not
your best model. It was actually NL-32
XL, which was a much worse model in
perplexity, right? This is a very common
thing that does often correlated. Um
this is probably one of the worst
correlations that I've seen from
upstream to downstream, but I think it's
very very important to remember that
scaling laws, generally speaking, are
objects that you want to apply on the
perplexity side. They're very clean,
they're very regular, they're very
predictable. But transfer from
perplexity to downstream is a lot less
certain than it might initially seem,
right? This is a place where you want to
be very cautious. Um
And you know, as an anecdote, um
I have I have former students that have
gone in and done post-training at
various places, and they always
complain. They're like, "Oh, those
pre-training people, you know, they hand
you this model. They're like, 'The
perplexity is good. It's all your
problem now.'" But it's often, you know,
the the problems have started at the at
the pre-training side, right? So, you
don't you don't want to be one of those
people. You want to really think about
transfer as well, not just uh focus on
perplexities.
Okay.
So, maybe this is surprising, maybe this
is not, but the point that I want to
drill in here is that, you know, before
you do your big training run, you should
have a rough idea of what you're going
to see, right? Not just like, is it
going to like train at all? In fact, if
you do scaling laws, you should be able
to actually predict, you know, fairly
precisely the numerical values almost of
how good your run is going to be, right?
If I choose one optimizer versus the
other, what will the gain be? Like you
should be able to predict that, right?
Um so, the scaling law-based procedure
is to say, "I'm going to train a bunch
of smaller models. I'm going to
establish some sort of a scaling law,
you know, by fitting these lines onto
log-log plots, and then if the fit is
good enough, I'm going to have some
confidence that the gap will persist,
and then I'm just going to deploy that
onto my large-scale training run, right?
This is the naive version of a scaling
law proc- procedure, but I think one
that is like reasonably accurate for how
you might think about these things in
practice, right? What else are you going
to do? Um just sort of deploy a run out
of nowhere? Probably not. Um
Okay. I can pause here and and take some
questions before I get into the the last
part of uh of this lecture.
Yes.
For each of the data points on the
scaling law, like how do you think about
variance? Like how many runs do you do?
And is this aggregation like average or
do you take minimum or maximum like
that?
Yeah, I think in most cases, if not all
cases that I've seen, um those are
singletons. And the reason why it's a
singleton is because when you're looking
at perplexities, perplexities are very
very clean, right? Like, you know, these
objects, if you rerun them, um you know,
they're probably like the variance is in
the second decimal place or something.
Um because the the training data is very
homogeneous, you've got a lot of it,
your eval sets are very big. You really
push the variance very very low on these
things. Um but if you're doing something
like, you know, um learning rate or
critical batch size scaling laws, you
will see some truly horrendous stuff. Um
I do think people do some variance
reduction, but it's actually not that
common. As common as it should be,
maybe.
Yes. What's
the most people use like just downstream
metrics um directly instead of using
perplexity?
Yeah, people do do scaling laws directly
on downstream metrics, but that has the
same problem as this. So, I think the
the way to think about scaling laws um
is to really reliably establish at least
one thing. So, so the way to think about
it is let's say I see something like
this, right? I know or, you know, I have
strong belief that this transformer line
is going to continue. This is a very
regular trend, right? And it might curve
a little bit, but we do think there's
probably some regularity here, right?
But instead, imagine this was a very
noisy jaggedy line of this form. You
would not really know what is going on.
Like you would say, "I maybe believe
that it will go on, but maybe it's a
line, maybe it's a curve, right?" So, I
think the general, you know, if I'm
trying to to explain the philosophy of
this stuff, is to say, "Okay, let's
start with a low variance measurement,
and then establish scaling regularity
there, and then rely on, you know, some
sort of belief about transfer or
establish transfer, you know, elsewhere
to try to show that that would transfer
over to downstream."
Oh, yeah.
So, some of these are for the test loss
and some are for the train loss. When do
you do either?
I see. Yes. Um you fit the test loss
when, you know, you're you're doing good
scientific practice like Kaplan 2021,
but realistically, um
all the
uh the models except for like a very
few, like the the infinite uh compute
one and like the repetition stuff,
unless you're doing some of that, um
you're all you're doing one-pass SGD.
So, the generalization gap for all of
these models is very very small, right?
So, train and val are very similar. Um
I've seen some pre-training codebases
that don't even have validation loss,
because if you're doing one pass,
most likely your train and val are very
very close. Um that's why a lot of these
plots sort of exchange those two because
they're all in the one-pass regime.
Good question, though. Okay.
All right. We will continue to move on
to Sorry, I moved on too far backwards
here. Okay.
So, now I'm going to talk about one of
the most well-known uses of a scaling
law, um even though you might not
personally be, you know, uh using this,
you've certainly used the rule of thumb
at some point. Um and also, I think
because this set of things will tell us
something really interesting about the
actual execution of a scaling law.
So, okay. The motivating question is, do
I want more data or bigger models,
right? So, you know, the resource that
you have, the resource that you have to
spend is compute, right? Someone's going
to hand you, metaphorically, certain
amount of flops, right? And you're going
to take those flops and you're going to
spend them somehow, you know, on if you
remember Percy's very first lecture,
right? It's going to be data times the
parameters is roughly your flops, right?
Linear in that.
So, do I want more data or more models?
Well,
we know that if we take, you know, a
teeny tiny model and we dump tons of
data into it, that will just be wasted.
That's kind of the uh you know, the dark
purple line at the very top here. I've
taken a teeny tiny language model and
I've, you know, passed a huge amount of
data into it, and this thing has been
flat for a very long time. You know,
this is a complete waste of compute,
right? You would have much rather
trained this big yellow model to the
same amount of tokens. Or even earlier
on, you know, if you're having the same
amount of compute.
Now, you know, if you could sort of
understand the interaction of how data
amount and model size come together to
sort of
uh give you performance, if you
understood that relationship, you could
optimize this very precisely, right? Um
and so, there are scaling laws that kind
of are more advanced and
relate kind of joint behaviors of
objects. So, um
almost simultaneously, um Kaplan and
Rosenfeld both sort of proposed these
kind of functional forms, which are
roughly equivalent, um describing how
the size of the model and the amount of
data relate to the error.
Um Rosenfeld's is very simple. It's
really just the sum of two inverse
terms. These are two scaling laws that
are added together.
Um and Kaplan's is a little bit more
complicated, but it's roughly the same
idea, right? Um and if you look at think
about the limits, this is very
intuitive, right? If I have an infinite
amount of data, right? Then what
happens? Then this goes to zero. You're
basically model size limited. You become
a pure model size scaling law. If I send
my model size to infinity, then I'm, you
know, I'm going to be bounded by data.
I'm going to have a pure data scaling
law, right? So, it makes sense if you
take the limits of both of these. It's a
often a a good idea if someone tells you
a scaling law to take the limits of all
the variables to understand uh the
behavior of the system.
Now, the thing that's kind of cool is um
Rosenfeld and many others that have
proposed these kinds of joint scaling
laws um
show that that these things fit quite
well even if you extrapolate. So, what
you're going to do is you're going to
fit on these green points, right? Which
is a low compute regime and low data
regime. You never see things that have
either high data or high model sizes,
right? And then you can extrapolate on
the basis of these tiny neurons in this
corner over here to essentially this
high compute or high data high model
size regime and you can very accurately
predict the error based on your
predictions.
Great sort of predictions, right? And so
once you have that, now what you can do
is to say, well, I have a fixed amount
of flops subject to my flops
constraints, minimize this, right?
That's a simple non-linear optimization
problem. You can do that to solve for
this.
Now, both Kaplan and
Rosenfeld provide equations of this
form.
What sort of
do they say? Well, if you look at Kaplan
and they solve for this equation, they
say something like this. Well,
the amount of
They always flip this. It confuses me.
The amount of data it should be C to the
0.73 and the amount of model size should
be C to the 0.27. All right, is that
reversed? I think it's reversed. Sorry.
N N should be the amount of parameters
and D should be the amount of data.
And so tokens per parameter as decreases
with C, right? So, as you increase the
compute amounts, this prescription by
Kaplan tells you to train bigger and
bigger and bigger models.
And so if you were around in the days of
GPT-3, it kind of shocks me to think
that there are people who were not. You
know, you would
know that there was a period where
everyone was training these like
gigantic models, right? Like they were
like hundreds of billions of parameters
of models, like trillion parameter dense
models, what have you?
And part of that was driven by this,
right? They saw GPT-3, they saw these
like Kaplan predictions and they said,
wow, I'm going to do my big training
runs on these gigantic, you know, model
size models. Um
But, you know, a few years later in
2022,
some folks at DeepMind, Hoffman and all
came in and they said, well, actually
these predictions are all terribly off,
right? You've been training these giant
models, these three stars over here, but
actually those are way too big. What we
should be training instead is a very
different trend, this this
line on the blue over here,
and we should be training this teal
star, which is a much better model,
right? So, they they argued that we
should be training much smaller models
relative to this.
And I think, you know, of course,
many of you or all of you probably know
the Chinchilla paper, you know, the what
the token multipliers are, right? It's
20 tokens to every parameter. But I
think this is useful to go in in detail
because the Chinchilla-Kaplan sort of
disagreement and like all of this tells
us something important about how we
should be thinking about scaling laws,
right? It's not just something where you
like turn the crank and you get the
answer. It's something that's actually
careful and sensitive and we have to,
you know, respect the process. Um
Okay, so I'm going to walk through the
Chinchilla paper and after I walk
through the Chinchilla paper, I'm going
to talk about why the Kaplan and
Chinchilla papers disagree and what that
means for you. Okay. So, the Chinchilla
authors suggest three different ways of
fitting scaling laws. I I really like
this because it's a way of, you know,
robustifying yourself to sort of
modeling assumptions you may have made.
Um and each of these actually is a quite
a different approach to estimating the
trade-off between
model size and data.
Um and minus method three, which does
differ a little bit, um they mostly
agree. Like all one and two both agree
that the coefficients for data and for
model size are roughly the same. 0.5 0.5
0.49 0.51. Method three does differ, you
know, 0.46 and 0.54, but we'll talk
about why later. Kaplan and all, of
course, have a very big difference
between the two, right? Which is why
they were training big big models at big
big compute sizes.
Method number one from Chinchilla is
what I might call like the lower
envelope method. And this is the method
that, you know, was also being used
partially by Kaplan to try to figure out
what the right scaling was. And so what
you do is you take all of your training
runs. So, each one of these colored
lines is a training curve, right? And
what you want to do is you want to
actually take the lower envelope of
these training curves, right? Because a
lower envelope point on this training
curve, that means that for a particular
flop, this is the best loss that I ever
achieved, right? For that flop on any
training run, right? So, I can take all
of the lower envelope points at the very
bottom here at the high compute regime
and then I can plot all those points to
see how big were the models that each of
these flop points intersected, right?
Because each of these points is a
training run with a model size. And if I
scatter plot that, I will get a nice
linear trend and that will give me one
way of estimating the trip optimal
trade-off between flops to parameters.
And that gives one answer, which is for
their compute budget, they should train
a 67 billion parameter model, right?
This is a nice and simple way,
but very tricky to finding things like
what is the lower envelope, so on and so
forth. Like there there's definitely
some tricky parts. Um
Method two is isoflops. This is now very
popular. It's also very easy and very
robust. This is probably my personal
favorite method.
And what you do is for this, you pick a
bunch of different flops budgets, right?
So, I have a different range of flops
budgets, you know, going in factors of
three in this case or even one three
six. Um and what you do is for each flop
budget, you're going to essentially
sweep the space, right? So, here I have
one variable, which is the parameter to
data trade-off. So, for each flop
budget, I'm going to sweep over the
parameter to data trade-off, fixing my
flops, right? So, I I double my data
size, I half my model size, so on and so
forth, right? And that will generate a
sequence of training runs whose terminal
loss is going to sweep out some sort of
curve, right? So, each one of these
colored sets of points is a fixed flop
run. Each point is sweeping across
different parameters and of course, it's
implicitly sweeping over data as well,
right? Now, the nice thing now is I can
take the minimum over each of these runs
or even fit a quadratic and take the
minimum over the quadratics and then I
can draw a line through all of the
bottoms of the quadratics or take, you
know, the bottom of the quadratics and
plot them as a function of flops to to
parameters
and that will give me another
prediction, which agrees very closely.
This is 63 billion parameters for my
compute budget.
Now, the final approach that
we can do is actually the maybe most
natural one as suggested by the
Rosenfeld paper as well as the Kaplan
paper because both of them
sort of propose a hypothesized
functional form for how model size and
data relate to loss, right? So, if you
have such a joint functional form, what
you can do is you can take, you know, a
whole bunch of training runs that you've
done and you can fit, you know, your
your loss landscape, right? Which is
your hypothesized functional form and
you can just do curve fitting to
estimate what the coefficients are in
your scaling law. This is the most brute
force way. You have a hypothesized
relationship between loss, data size and
model size, train a bunch of models, do
curve fitting, right? Hopefully fairly
straightforward, you know, how how you
do that. Of course, if you're doing this
method, how you do the curve fitting is
very important, right? Now you're
fitting these surfaces, there's many
variables, it's kind of tricky.
You know, this thing also has some
trickiness
just like method one, right? So, it's
not it's not a straightforward way
the same way that maybe isoflops is.
Okay. So now, you know, that we've gone
through what Chinchilla does, it doesn't
seem materially different than what
Kaplan was doing, right? It's not like
Kaplan was doing one crazy thing and
then the Chinchilla authors did
something like way smarter and you said,
wow, why didn't we do that from the the
start, right? They both did pretty
reasonable stuff. But if we look at
their scaling predictions, they are very
different, right? And in hindsight, we
generally, you know, tend to agree with
the fact that the Chinchilla authors had
more of the correct scaling, right? If
you do your own Chinchilla style
analysis, you will find probably scaling
is much closer to Chinchilla.
Now, so why is there such a big
difference when they're both fitting
these like joint scaling laws?
Okay, so
this is I think where we get into kind
of the messy realities of how scaling
laws are made, right? Scaling laws can
really change depending on the precise
ways in which you're implementing the
scaling laws, the hyperparameter
settings that you're using and even like
what the x-axis is. So, there's a a
really nice paper. Oh no, I covered the
authors. Okay, you can I I can paste
this in the in the uh uh lecture Slack
later. Um called Resolving Discrepancies
in Compute Optimal Scaling of Language
Models. Y Yi is the last author. He was
a former student here. Um and they, you
know, show basically first, they
replicate the Kaplan result, you know,
using roughly the Kaplan settings. And
then they say, okay, well, you know,
let's change how we count parameters.
They that shifts the curve a little bit.
And then they say, okay, well, let's
change how learning rate warm-up is
done. That shifts the curve a little
bit. And then let's tune the optimizer a
little bit more. And then they get
exactly kind of the Chinchilla result,
right? So, their argument here is that
there's a sequence of what seems like
very minor decisions that in the end
gives you this big gap between the
Kaplan scaling law and the Chinchilla
scaling law, right?
Um and I'll explain what each of these
steps is, not that that's like the most
important single thing, but also to
emphasize to you how kind of important
the details are here, right? So, the
very first arrow where we go from Kaplan
to the blue line, that is how we count
parameters. So, remember in Kaplan I
said, well, they saw this weird stuff if
they included embedding parameters,
right? So, they excluded embedding
parameters. That's generally an okay
thing to do,
but one thing they also did that really
messed them up was they also excluded
the the last layer parameter counts,
right? The the softmax ones because in
many models, kind of the embedding and
the last layer linear are dual to each
other, right? Like they have the same
shapes, right? The inside has vocab size
by hidden dim, the output matrix has
hidden dim by vocab size. And because
they're the same shape, they said,
"Well, let's just exclude both of
those."
Turns out, whether you include or
exclude those has a big material impact
on the shape of the scaling law, right?
They also found This is much more of
kind of a oversight more than a genuine
sort of difference in opinion that a lot
of the models that were being trained in
Kaplan were very small. In fact, they
were so small that they were not
actually converging by the time that the
learning rate warm-up was done, right?
So, their learning rates were set very
suboptimally. And because of that, you
know, their models weren't fully
converged.
And then finally, they found that, you
know, Kaplan et al. was fixing one big
batch size, and those big batch sizes
were suboptimal for the smaller models.
And therefore, you know, if you tune
that correctly and use varying batch
sizes, you end up getting this sort of
thing that agrees exactly with
Chinchilla, right? So, I think each of
these might seem like a very minor
difference,
but if you sort of change up these
really minor you can get big shifts in
the scaling law. And one thing I kind of
like to emphasize is that scaling laws
are kind of lower bounds in some sense,
right? They're kind of saying, "If I
continue this recipe and I scale it up,
then this is what I will get, right?"
But if you're scaling up sort of a
recipe that you don't want to scale up,
like your warm-up is kind of crazy or
your batch sizes are crazy, you're going
to get bad scaling laws, right? So, you
want to be as close to the proper sort
of full run as possible.
There's another paper that does another
very interesting thing to try to study
the difference between Kaplan and
Chinchilla scaling laws. It's by Pearson
and Song.
And what they do, and I think this is
very clever, is they don't train any
models. They just take the Chinchilla
training curves or like or the implied
functional form of the Chinchilla
training curves. They just plot them
out, and they say, "Well, based on
these, you know, implied training
curves, which are simulated purely from
Chinchilla, they generate what the
implied training curves will be for
Kaplan if you ignore the embedding
parameters and scale way down, and what
happens if you use the total parameter
count instead." And what they find is
really two effects. One is that Kaplan
is operating at a much lower compute
scale, so they're very sensitive to
small changes. And actually, ignoring
the non-embedding parameter is a
sufficiently big change to mess up the
result relative to Chinchilla. So, their
their argument is slightly different
from Yair and others, which is that here
actually, it's the size of the compute
scale plus the slight nonlinearity
induced by non-embedding parameters
that's causing this this disagreement,
right?
So, this is really, you know, starting
to get into the weeds, but I hope you
kind of appreciate, you know, the
importance of paying attention to
detail, right? And I think a lot of the
the work that goes on in establishing
reliable scaling laws is about figuring
out what the right regime is so that you
can get reliable scaling across, you
know, compute scales.
The final thing,
and this is really just more of
something that I just find amusing more
than anything else,
which is that, you know, Chinchilla is
this paper that kind of takes down the
Kaplan paper in a way, right? Like, "Oh,
you guys were very wrong."
But there was this one remaining
mystery, which is that Chinchilla method
three never agreed with Chinchilla
method one and two, right? And the
numbers look small, and the authors are
are very unperturbed about this, but I
think the implications are quite
nontrivial. Like, if you look at this,
method one and two basically say, you
know, the amount of parameters and
tokens should scale together, right? So,
there should be a fixed ratio between
the two. This is where kind of the
Chinchilla factor of 20 comes from.
If you look at, you know, number three,
the exponents are different. This means
if you scale up your compute,
eventually, actually in this case,
you're going to have way more tokens
than you are going to have parameters,
right? So, it's going to be actually a
very different scaling conclusion
asymptotically than the other ones.
And so,
turns out that
you know, I was certainly not the only
ones perturbed about this, except some
folks at Epoch AI did something about
being perturbed.
They couldn't get either the raw data or
the code. So, what they did was they
extracted the data from plots in the
paper, and they refitted the method
three regressions. Like, they extracted
the data from the paper, and given that
data, they fitted that sort of 2D
surface or sorry, 3D surface
that was proposed.
And then, what they showed is actually
the original paper must have underfitted
the original data. And if they redid
sort of the curve fitting, they could
get much lower losses relative to what
sort of the the proposed scaling law in
the Chinchilla paper. And in fact, if
you follow the refitted model, you got
almost exactly the
you know, D over 20 is 20 rule of thumb
from the Chinchilla paper, right? Which
is really a funny conclusion, I think,
to the Chinchilla paper, where in the
end, it turns out that, you know, the
authors were more right than they knew,
right? Actually, they they had made a
mistake, and that was the only reason
why method three disagreed from methods
one and two. So, it's kind of a nice
sort of conclusion to know that the
method was robust after all.
Okay.
So, that's the the end of the Chinchilla
saga in some ways, but
I will end this section by saying you
probably don't want the Chinchilla
factor. At this point, I think this is a
pretty common, you know, knowledge
thing.
But if you're training a production
model, right? You don't really care
about saving training compute for the
most part. You can look at all sorts of
external surveys that people have done
of how frontier labs are spending their
compute. Most of the compute is not
going into training runs, right? Most of
the compute is actually going into R&D
and serving, right? And given that,
especially for serving, what you want to
do is you want small models that are
capable, right? You do not want big,
bloated models that cost a lot to serve,
even if that minimizes training cost.
And so,
what you really want is something that
you would call as overtrained. I put
that in quotes because really,
overtraining is what we want. That's the
right amount of training.
And if you look at all the models that
were released, you know, in the early
days, like GPT-3, this was undertrained
for sure, right? Three tokens per
parameter. Chinchilla gets to the modern
ratio of 20 per parameter. And then for
a while, people were at 20 per
parameter. And this is the era, I think,
where there wasn't that much serving of
these models, right? The models were
cool, but it wasn't being served at
scale. And then as you sort of start to
move to eras where, you know, serving
becomes very real, now you're
overtraining these models, and now
you've moved into MoEs, and you're
making all these tradeoffs to optimize
inference serving, right?
So, I think Chinchilla is important not
because I think the 20:1 ratio is, you
know, the one golden ratio. If you're
doing stuff for research, it might be.
But I think the reason why it's
important is because it tells us quite a
bit about how we should be fitting
scaling laws and how to think about
scaling laws.
Okay.
One final thing I'll end with
Chinchilla-wise and and otherwise for
scaling is isoflops have been one of the
things that I think as a research tool
have endured.
Isoflops are very easy to execute,
right? You fix a flop budget, and then
you sweep over all of the other degrees
of freedom to see kind of what the
surface looks like. And this gives you
in general
fairly reliable readings of how
different parameters vary as a function
of your of your
of your free parameters. You know,
people have done this for or actually
actually my one of my students did this
for diffusion models. You know, the MoE
study I talked about was a isoflop style
design. If you're ever in a situation
where you're thinking, "How am I going
to sort of decide all these tradeoffs?"
isoflops is always a good default.
Okay.
So, to to wrap up everything for today,
you know, there's this idea that, you
know, we have this log-linear regularity
between the amount of resources we put
in and the performance we get out,
right? It extends to a wide variety of
things, model parameters, compute,
sparsity level of your MoE. And that
lets you do a lot of the things that I
was talking about earlier as like
arbitrary choices, but do it in a much
more evidence-driven way, hopefully.
And so, this allows us to have
engineering at scale without explicitly
relying on
doing big model training runs, okay? And
hopefully, you remember, I think, all
the different components here. Data
scaling is this very natural object.
Just the exponent is a little bit
strange. Model scaling allows you to do
all these cool engineering things. And
then finally, scaling is this very cool,
robust predictor, let's call it, for how
to try to
do engineering at large scale.
And thanks. Next lecture, I think, will
be Percy on inference, but after that,
we will return to more advanced niche
scaling topics.